If it's been a while since you've seen the
first two Jumanji films or if you've avoided
the sinister game until now we've got you
covered.
We've gathered everything you need to know
before you see Jumanji: The Next Level, including
past events, new characters, and more.
Gather up your gear, because we're heading
back into the jungle.
The original Jumanji film is based on the
1981 picture book of the same name by Chris
Van Allsburg in which a pair of siblings named
Judy and Peter Shepherd come across the titular
board game in the park.
In the films, the characters come upon the
game in much the same way, with all of them
happening upon it seemingly by accident — although
the films imply that the game has a degree
of sentience to it and can manipulate circumstances
so that it can be found and played.
After finding a board game called Jumanji
at a construction site in 1969, Alan Parrish
begins playing with his friend, Sarah Whittle.
However, they've barely begun to play before
Alan is sucked into the game, with a message
that he must wait in the jungle until someone
rolls a five or eight.
But instead of taking her turn, the terrified
Sarah flees from the house, and the game is
placed in the attic.
Later, in 1995, orphans Judy and Peter Shepherd
move into Alan Parrish's old house with their
aunt and discover the game in the attic.
They begin to play, and Peter's roll releases
Alan from the game.
"Where's my mom and dad?"
"We don't know.
Everyone thought you were dead."
Now an adult, Alan has been living in the
jungle for the past 26 years, and he uses
the skills he's acquired there to help the
children fend off the animals and natural
disasters that emerge from the game.
However, since the game from 1969 was never
finished, they have to find the adult Sarah
and convince her to take her turn so that
they can complete the game and return everything
to normal.
After taking turns that result in the game
unleashing increasingly catastrophic levels
of mayhem and destruction, Alan finally finishes
the game and says …
"Jumanji."
Everything is returned to its pre-game state,
including Alan going back to 1969, where he
grows up to marry Sarah and prevent the accident
that killed Judy and Peter's parents.
While the game of Jumanji is undeniably tricky
and deliberately misleading, it is, at its
heart, still a game.
The rules written on the board game state:
"You roll the dice to move your token, doubles
get another turn, and the first player to
reach the end wins."
With each turn, the game creates a new obstacle
for the players to face, making it progressively
more difficult to finish the game.
Through playing, the characters learn that
no one can forfeit, leave the game, or skip
a turn, and there are consequences for attempting
to cheat in order to end the game sooner.
After completing their final turn, the winning
player must say the word "Jumanji" out loud
in order to end the game.
Over the course of the films, however, the
board game shifts its form to become a video
game.
So naturally, some of the rules had to change,
but the basics have stayed the same.
Dice-specific stipulations such as the doubles
rule no longer apply, but players still have
to complete the game once it's started, can't
forfeit or quit, and have to say "Jumanji"
out loud in order to finish it.
In both Jumanji and Jumanji: Welcome to the
Jungle, a player gets trapped inside the game
for decades due to no one being able to beat
it.
In Alan Parrish's case, his problem was that
Sarah stopped playing, and therefore didn't
roll the five or eight that was needed in
order to bring him out.
Even when Judy and Peter thought they were
starting a new game, they were really just
continuing Alan and Sarah's game from 26 years
earlier.
Then in Welcome to the Jungle, Alex gets caught
inside the game for 21 years after his father
finds it on the beach in 1996, where it washed
up after Alan and Sarah threw it into the
river in 1969.
While the original version of Jumanji was
a board game, and thus required at least two
players, once it shifted into a quest-based
video game version, it became possible to
play as a solo player.
However, while Alex technically could've completed
the game by himself, he wound up stuck when
he came up against an obstacle he couldn't
get past on his own.
Like Alan, Alex required other players to
join in later to finish the game and return
them all to their pre-game state.
If you're unlucky enough to get caught inside
Jumanji, and there's no one around to take
the next turn or you can't complete the game
on your own, you'll simply be stuck "playing"
forever.
Unlike Sarah and Alan or Judy and Peter, the
four teenagers who go on to play the game
in Welcome to the Jungle aren't friends, siblings,
or really much of anything.
Spencer, Bethany, Martha, and Fridge are all
students at Brantford High School, and that's
about where their similarities end.
Spencer and Fridge were best friends as kids,
but now their relationship consists entirely
of Spencer doing Fridge's homework for him,
and while Spencer admires Martha from afar,
they don't really talk.
Meanwhile, Bethany is off in her own self-absorbed
world, and she doesn't seem to notice any
of the others.
The four are sentenced to serve detention
together in the school's storage room on a
Saturday, removing staples from magazines
so they can be recycled.
Rather than engage in their tedious task,
they decide to play a video game Fridge discovers
among the shelves, and soon, they find themselves
trapped inside Jumanji.
After a harrowing adventure inside the game,
including a number of near-death and actual
death experiences, the four learn to lean
on and appreciate one another, and they emerge
from the game as good friends with a new outlook
on life.
Bethany learns to be brave and selfless, Martha
finds confidence, Fridge learns humility,
and Spencer learns to lead and conquer his
fears.
In addition, Fridge and Spencer rekindle their
friendship, and Spencer and Martha embark
on a romantic relationship.
While the main characters of Jumanji: Welcome
to the Jungle are Spencer, Martha, Fridge,
and Bethany, the people we spend the most
time watching in the film aren't technically
people at all.
Instead, they're video game avatars.
Avatars are characters that exist within the
game and are controlled by outside players,
and in Welcome to the Jungle, each character
spends most of the film occupying the body
of their chosen avatar.
"I look like a living garden gnome!
Where is my phone?!"
"Who cares?"
"We are in different people's bodies."
Each avatar has its own strengths and weaknesses,
which remain with the avatar no matter which
player is controlling it.
Ruby Roundhouse — Martha's avatar — is
proficient in karate, T'ai chi, aikido, and
dance fighting, though her weakness is venom.
Bethany's avatar is Professor Oberon and his
strengths are cartography, archaeology, and
paleontology, and his weakness is endurance.
Meanwhile, Mouse — the avatar of Fridge
— boasts an impressive knowledge of zoology
and an equally impressive variety of weapons,
while his weaknesses are cake, speed, and
strength.
Spencer's avatar is Smolder Bravestone and
his strengths are speed, throwing boomerangs,
climbing, being "fearless," and his "smoldering
intensity."
He has zero weaknesses.
Seaplane McDonough — the avatar of Alex
— tells us that his strengths are piloting
and margaritas, and that one of his weaknesses
is mosquitoes, but he doesn't mention what
the others may be.
Although the board game version of Jumanji
had several rules specific to rolling dice,
the video game version adapts the mechanics
of its gameplay to fit its new format.
Now instead of taking turns, the players work
together to complete levels, each with its
own goals and challenges.
The levels get increasingly more difficult
as players progress through the game, and
all build toward an ultimate end goal.
Additionally, each character starts the game
with three lives, although it's possible for
one player to transfer one of their extra
lives to another player under dire circumstances.
If a player dies, assuming they have an additional
life, they'll respawn, along with any objects
they were holding when they died, appearing
in the sky over the game and landing in approximately
the same spot.
Jumanji also contains several NPCs or non-player
characters that interact with the characters'
avatars and either guide them on their way
or attempt to work against them.
The main NPCs in Welcome to the Jungle are
Nigel, who serves as a guide for the characters,
and Van Pelt, who's the game's antagonist.
Van Pelt also existed in the board game version
of Jumanji as a big game hunter determined
to keep Alan and the other players from completing
the game.
In Welcome to the Jungle, Van Pelt is given
a more thorough backstory and a similar goal
to the player characters, but his role as
the game's resident bad guy appears to be
a Jumanji constant.
So what exactly happens in Jumanji: Welcome
to the Jungle?
Well, after getting trapped inside Jumanji,
and after a period of initial confusion and
denial, Spencer, Martha, Fridge, and Bethany
have to work together to deliver a magical
jewel called the Jaguar's Eye to a giant jaguar
statue before the sinister Russell Van Pelt
can get his hands on it.
Possessed by the power of the jewel, Van Pelt
is able to control Jumanji's animals, which
works against the players as they attempt
to complete their task.
The group is given clues meant to inform their
quests, which leads them to Alex's avatar,
who'd started the game in 1996 but had gotten
stuck when he found himself down to his last
life on a challenge he didn't know how to
complete.
Drawing on their avatars' collective strengths,
the group is finally able to beat the level
that had thwarted Alex for so long, although
Alex loses his last life in the process, and
Bethany has to transfer one of her extra lives
to him through CPR.
The five players reach the statue, return
the jewel, and call out, "Jumanji," ending
the game.
Shaking hands with each of them, Nigel returns
them to their lives at the moment before they
entered the game.
The four Brantford High teens walk to the
previously run-down Vreeke home, where they
encounter a now grown-up Alex, who tells them
he'd emerged from the game in 1996 and had
lived a good life, naming his oldest daughter
Bethany.
Later, the four teens destroy the game.
Almost every major player from Jumanji: Welcome
to the Jungle is coming back for Jumanji:
The Next Level, although we'll get to see
several of them in a brand new light.
In fact, the entire main cast including Rhys
Darby's Nigel and Colin Hanks' Alex will be
returning for the next installment in the
series.
The only significant character from Welcome
to the Jungle who hasn't been confirmed for
the sequel is Bobby Cannavale, who played
the villainous Van Pelt.
However, while most of the faces in The Next
Level will be familiar, some of the actors
will be portraying totally different characters.
Due to Jumanji's use of avatars, only Karen
Gillan will be portraying the same player
as she did in Welcome to the Jungle.
Fridge, who played as Kevin Hart's Mouse Finbar
the first time around, will now be controlling
Jack Black's Shelly Oberon, while Dwayne "The
Rock" Johnson and Hart will be portraying
the avatars of two brand-new characters: Spencer's
grandfather, Eddie, and Eddie's friend, Milo.
We've yet to learn which avatars Bethany and
Spencer wind up controlling, or if Alex re-enters
the game at all, but one thing's for sure
this game will be very different from the
last one.
"We're gonna die."
"We did die."
"Are we in hell?"
"I knew it."
Joining the cast for Jumanji: The Next Level
are comedic acting legends Danny DeVito and
Danny Glover, playing Spencer's grandfather,
Eddie Gilpin, and his friend, Milo Walker,
respectively.
If The Next Level follows the same format
as Welcome to the Jungle, we don't expect
to see DeVito and Glover on screen for very
long, but it looks like the characters will
still have a significant presence in the movie
after they accidentally enter the game and
wind up controlling the avatars portrayed
by Dwayne Johnson and Kevin Hart.
Also coming aboard for the next Jumanji outing
are Once Upon a Time's Dania Ramirez and Crazy
Rich Asians and The Farewell star Awkwafina,
both in undisclosed roles.
While Ramirez doesn't appear in the trailer
at all, the brief glimpse we get of Awkwafina
suggests that she'll be playing a character
within the game, although whether she'll be
another avatar or a new NPC is anyone's guess.
Whoever she is, sources have told The Hollywood
Reporter that Awkwafina's role is more significant
than just a cameo leading us to guess that
she's likely either an avatar for one of the
players possibly Spencer, Bethany, or even
Alex or she's the game's new villain.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.